[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: Hi there.
I'm Jimmy.
HEATHER CROSS: And I'm Heather.
We're here to launch
a new series focusing
on Google Cloud.
We'll showcase some
interactive demos and labs
and discuss different GCP
products with experts.
JIMMY TRAN: That's right.
Our first topic to
kick off this series
is around IAM, or Identity
Access Management.
HEATHER CROSS: Let's get to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: Identity
Access Management
is how you decide who can do
what with your Google Cloud
resources.
You can get incredibly specific
when you create an IAM policy,
but essentially, you
have an identity, a role,
and a resource.
HEATHER CROSS: Think of it
as an air traffic controller
for your business.
An organization's internal
structure and policies
can get complex fast.
Projects, work
groups, and managing
who has authorization to do
what can change dynamically.
JIMMY TRAN: Cloud
IAM is designed
with a clean
universal interface,
so you're able to manage access
control across all Google Cloud
Platform resources consistently
from App Engine to GCE.
HEATHER CROSS: Keep
in mind, Cloud IAM
is offered at no additional
charge for GCP customers.
You'll only be charged
for use of other services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: Ah, G
Suite, my roots.
You know, it feels
like yesterday
when we were just doing--
HEATHER CROSS: Jimmy,
we've got a lot to cover.
JIMMY TRAN: OK.
Fine.
Speaking of G Suite, Cloud
IAM supports standard Google
accounts.
That means you can
manage users and groups
through the Google Admin
console, all in one place.
HEATHER CROSS: You can
create cloud IAM policies,
granting permission to a
Google group, a Google hosted
domain, a service account, or
specific Google account holders
using Cloud Identity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: A full audit trail
of permissions authorization,
removal, and delegation
is surfaced automatically
for your admins.
Cloud IAM lets you focus
on business policies
around your resources and
makes compliance easy.
HEATHER CROSS: For
established enterprises
with complex
organizational structures,
hundreds of work groups, and
potentially many more projects,
Cloud IAM provides a unified
view and a security policy
across your entire organization
with built-in auditing
to ease compliance processes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIMMY TRAN: And now the
fun part, quick laps.
HEATHER CROSS: As a
part of the series,
we'll highlight a demo or
lab of each product or use
case we discuss.
We want you to get your
hands dirty by experimenting
with the products themselves.
So we have quick
lab environments
set up for your testing.
JIMMY TRAN: You can check out
the link to start the quick lab
yourself here.
Keep in mind, these take
about a half hour or more.
Let's jump into the lab.
We're joining the lab at the
section where user one removes
project access from user two.
This task easily shows how
to add and remove permissions
to a user.
Here's what happens.
At this point in the
lab, as user one,
you have a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
User two currently has
access to the file.
Now, as user one, remove
user two's permissions.
As user two, try to
access the file and fail.
Now, back to user one.
Give user two permission
to view the bucket.
Finally, as user two,
access the bucket.
HEATHER CROSS: Well, that's
all the time we have for today.
We hope you enjoy
the series and would
love to hear more
about how you use,
or would use, Cloud
Identity Access
Management at your business.
JIMMY TRAN: That's right.
And you can learn more
through our on-air webinar
series, Quiklabs, and our blog.
All the links are below.
HEATHER CROSS: Also, make sure
to check out Google Cloud's
on demand courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]